all right so Joe Biden's week foreign
policy was on full display this week as
he met with President chi in California
amid Rising tensions between the US
China well Biden and Chi took steps to
help the relationship now but still many
are you know on the lingering issues of
economic political world order tensions
they all remain as a matter of fact I
don't think China is going to move an
inch on any of the important issues
meanwhile experts are raising the alarm
after Biden C in to the green New Deal
climate alarmist cultist once again
struck an agreement with Chi to move
towards shutting down fossil fuels dumb
again and earlier this week the
administration extended the sanctions
waiver allowing Iraq to buy electricity
from Iran freeing up a massive $1
billion windfall for the world's largest
state sponsor of terrorism here with
reaction former Secretary of State Fox
News contributor Mike Pompeo
you know Mr secretary really you know it
we we know of Iran's involvement in the
terrorist attacks on October 7th we know
that they plotted we know they planned
we know they trained we know they
provided Weaponry for this attack
against our number one Ally in the
region now Joe Biden gives what four
month extension and allows Iran to get
paid 10 billion more dollars I don't
have an answer for this why would they
possibly think that's a good
idea Sean good evening uh look it's
confounding there's no there's no good
explanation for why they've given all
this money to them right don't forget it
was not too long ago that there was $6
billion paid in Ransom to get five
Americans home and now more Americans
are actually held hostage by the Iranian
regime now in Gaza wh why you turn
around and give them billions and
billions more is just simply
unexplainable as is the fact Sean that
right we've had over four dozen attacks
on American soldiers in the Middle East
in just the last 5 weeks and the
response from this Administration has
been almost nothing I I'm worried
because I am confident that the
Ayatollah and president risi in Iran
that they view this weakness as a green
light for further actions further
actions maybe in the Middle East in Gaza
maybe in Israel um but perhaps further
actions here inside the United States as
well we've got millions of people
trooping across our border don't think
for a moment that some of them couldn't
be associated with Iranian terrorist
activity you talked about them being the
world's largest sponsor of Terror they
have a global Terror campaign and
they're determined to use it to their
advantage against the president of the
United States who refuses to stand up to
them do you agree with me that China now
is officially our number one
geopolitical foe that has now aligned
with Russia and the mullers in
Iran absolutely not close back in May of
20 nion liary I spoke about this this
very thing that CCP as being the central
threat to our children and
grandchildren's way of life life they're
at the center of most of the challenges
that America will face in the next
decade okay so when we look at China we
see intellectual property theft we see
unfair Trade Practices uh we see hostile
actions against our air our air force in
international Airways uh International
waterways hostile actions towards our
Navy they threaten our Ally Taiwan uh
the Spy balloon incident then we have Co
and there are never any consequences for
any of these actions and Joe wants to
kind of keep hitting the reset button
thinking I guess that at some point
China's going to like us and they're
going to start being nice to us uh why
do I believe that is beyond naive and
that that President she is just going to
do whatever he wants regardless of what
Joe Biden says or
does uh you believe that Sean because uh
the evidence points to that there's not
a single example where shiing ping has
actually lived up to a promise he's made
to reduce his threat to the United
States he told President Obama in 2015
stood in the Rose Garden said I'm not
going to arm the spratley islands he
turned around and armed them uh he told
the people of Hong Kong you'll get 50
years uh he took that over uh the list
of shishin Ping's lies is long and so
for President Biden to to sit with him
and say hey let's work on climate change
together xingping says oh my goodness
absolutely you restrict your energy you
harm your economy you buy all this green
product from us
and then we'll see what we'll do about
our calf fire power plants Sean you and
I can both predict how many coal fire
power plants will be shut down by China
in the next two years I think the answer
is literally zero they will they will
lie he will promise whatever it takes to
get through the meeting and President
Biden foolishly accepted those
commitments including the commitment to
reduce fentanyl precursors which I don't
think shinging will ever do he he bought
these commitments as real promises from
the Chinese Communist party and there's
no reason to believe he will live up to
any of them I read conflicting reports
perhaps you can set the record straight
I read on the one hand that China's been
building building up their military for
the last 10 years on the other hand they
have a declining population uh their
economy is in a bit of a shambles
they're not doing as well as people
think um what is the most likely
scenario based on your past knowledge
and
insight so both of those are true the
Chinese Communist party's economy is
struggling coming out of Co after their
massive lockdowns and their military is
stronger today than it was yesterday and
it'll be stronger two years from now
than it is today so both of those are
true uh xingping doesn't care about the
economy he he only cares about the
capacity to build out his hegemonic
power he has clearly prioritized
military power and his capacity to
threaten Taiwan over entrepreneurs and
the economy inside of China that's
different than previous Chinese leaders
xingping is definitely a different
communist dictator
and so the the likelihood that he
becomes a friend of the United States of
America is literally zero I appreciate
you being with us the IDF continues to
expose Hamas and their brutality every
single day we're going to show you uh
what they found near a school in Gaza
that's straight
ahead hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else